for decades it has been the one thing
the global economy could rely on a
steady supply of oil from Saudi Arabia
now the attack on the seemingly
impregnable Saudi oil plants sending
fears through financial markets what
we're looking at on what we've seen over
the summer is a world in which the
amount of oil were producing every day
is less than the amount of oil that we
consume it that's been masked by the
fact that everybody's worried about a
global economic slowdown but the reality
is the disruption to Saudi production
simply adds to an existing tightness in
the balance between supply of oil and
demand oil prices have been higher this
year but not since the first Gulf War in
the early 90s if they shot up quite so
quickly in a single trading session the
air freight sector knows this better
than most
as one of the leading barometers for the
state of the global economy they've
already seen the impact of the growing
trade war there at the front line of
brexit and now fresh concerns about the
threat of an oil price shop with serious
consequences it's starting to worry us
to start to various already so we will
have to look at our fuel surcharges that
we put through to our clients and say
hey sorry we've got to charge you a
little bit more what reaction that we'll
have I'm not sure but we will no doubt
see the payloads that we're carrying
reduce because people will be buying
less and make no mistake this still
matters
these containers have just come off a
flight from Hong Kong and from here
they'll be transported around the
country on lorries kerosene diesel
petrol it's a useful reminder that for
all that we think we're moving towards a
world of net zero carbon emissions for
the time being crude oil is still
essential for global trade which is why
so many people are concerned about
what's happening in Saudi Arabia it's a
lesson to the seventies oil crisis may
feel like ancient history but that is
not the first time a Middle Eastern
conflict sparked a global energy
shortage it may not be the last at
Conway Sky News